all right so we're finally here at PAX
at the fortress in Seattle checking out
Mortal Kombat and actually have a
surprise guest for you guys here with
Edie Boone the man the myth the legend
behind Mortal Kombat is there anything
you can tell us about this game that we
haven't heard before is something new
something awesome something that you
haven't heard before uh well I guess I
don't know what you've heard before but
I guess it's this is the first time that
it's playable to the public which we're
really excited about so far you know
we're getting a really great reception
you know there's gonna be a slow
unveiling of all the characters coming
out but it's you know Mortal Kombat
returning back to its roots 2d gameplay
m-rated presentation fatalities
you know deeper fighting engines so it's
a worksites we couldn't be happier about
how it's turning out I agree I agree I'm
a longtime Mortal Kombat fan I've loved
what I've seen so far the main question
I always get is how many fatalities can
we expect from each character how many
from each character I think you can
expect at least two per character these
different gears yeah fantastic now the
big unveiling recently was Cyrax and
katana I take it you can't tell me any
more than that but or can you well I
could tell you that and I've been saying
this all along is um if you have a
favorite character from Mortal Kombat
one two and three there's a pretty good
chance that they're gonna be in the game
so Barack is back well if you have a
favorite character from all combat three
that's pretty good chance Barack is back
this is this is nitty gritty this is no
no babe a letís no friendships pit
fatalities how many of those can we
expect like the stage fatality multiple
ones um I guess I guess I'm haven't even
decided how many yet but I would imagine
you're gonna have at least five
something like that you know but as far
as like you know fatalities and maladies
and friendships and all that stuff this
work we're probably trying to take this
one a little bit more serious we're not
going to go crazy with it but if we were
to put something in there we definitely
wouldn't announce it we definitely want
people to the whole rumor thing that was
part of what was Mortal Kombat was
rumors oh yeah and all that oh yeah I
heard you could climb into the tree hole
and fight the Keebler elves like I mean
I tried every which way I tried to fight
the Keebler elves it's not in Mortal
Kombat 2 is it I can't fight the Keebler
Elf they're not all right so you say
you're you're still developing stages as
we speak so I mean it's still on the fly
you're like oh I want that stage in
there no cap we have them all mapped out
we're creating the content for now but
we know all the backgrounds that are
going to be in the game and we know you
know for the most part which ones are
going to have stage fatalities okay
fantastic now what's the expected
release date I've heard 2011 I don't
know when 2011 fall Oh
it'll probably be in the first the first
half I would I would guess March or
April would be my guess fantastic yeah
that's around my birthday that's perfect
ed boom thank you very much I'll let you
go in big fan love all your work keep
them coming
by first of all I'd like to thank ed
boon for taking time out of his day to
talk with us about Mortal Kombat he
didn't have to do that and that's why
he's a badass human being and now I'm
gonna go play the game
all right so I played the game twice
first with katana got wasted not gonna
lie I wanted to play it again to have
some fun a second time was with Molina
much better experience fantastic
gameplay I mean it was old-school I was
doing the old school moves juggling in
the air this is the return of Mortal
Kombat and I'm just glad I'm alive to
see it happen and you heard it from boon
himself March or April be in the stores
I know I'm going to be